hello and welcome to this video playing
Ready Steady Go
I assume so
hmm what does the bingo gambit lead to
here in the case taking everything yeah
my banker patois
it's been ages since I since I'm
refreshed my memory there so I still
like to play this opening at CERN in
particular I think suitable for quicker
time controls but you really have to be
you have to be knowledgeable and
[Music]
sometimes not so easy to remember the
details okay it's a funky move on an
idea interesting idea 3 and then he 3 is
quite uncommon many more refute the Bank
ofit I was just thinking about it's
interesting okay yeah problem now is the
moment to to take out a 6
yeah I can just build up the standard
Banco setup I don't think that's
something particularly bad about it you
always have to be on the lookout for
this a form 95 idea that is something
that can be extremely problematic but
seem well is going for it's got a for it
at least
and now how do we how do we handle this
currently it doesn't even have a for
plate
I'm a bit unsure where I should put the
Queen
I can just go bees to b6 but but
uncertain death
hmm should be five or move
yeah stick I want to fight against this
night
straightaway and also had 94 that was
interesting that was good
actually ma'am do I not and put it on to
the central square and even f5 after
that is not out of the picture okay but
what I'm trying is simply to get rid of
this piece on b5 night only b5 supported
by the pawn only four can be extremely
annoying because it just blocks the
whole Queen side play okay
I'm ready to trade off the night on
c-form
quickly with Knight b6 on 95 that is
important okay it's a good night b6
after night you father me and my Knight
b6 he has ya prevented very thoroughly
okay mmm how do I get rid of this thing
here I could ready myself for Knight b6
that that doesn't hit me with the tempo
[Music]
any other way I could try to get ya this
is an idea actually
Queen to b7 was an idea for Queen b3 or
Queen b5 where the night's stability is
a little bit endangered Queen B fires
actually interesting that puts a bit of
pressure on the piece itself and the
detects a 5 so you can imagine a line
like 3 to b5 why does whatever and I
play 95 and then after Knight b6 I can
take a five now white is taking ages
here ages but you see
yeah okay you form yeah clean b5 that
was my idea and I still like it so let's
not second-guess it yeah in 95
yeah that must be okay basically Queen
b3 is a normal way to do this but yeah
let's go in b3 b2 is a ticket it's still
not entirely certain how I get this back
be a pawn hmm
is he threatening a6 that's an
interesting question
I'm not sure about it no better safe
than sorry I came it could maybe it was
an important temple now also don't have
that much time
yeah this is a dual purpose move okay
did not think about this just look c1
take this
I totally forgot about that that she
just takes c4 shoot I have spoiled this
position oh my god entirely unnecessary
that was it was just a question I mean
okay let's not get there it was just a
question how much better I was like him
no yeah it wasn't clearly meant or
anything but this is an excellent Banco
position then I had like here this is
just very okay for black it must be okay
because everything worked very nicely
for me I got rid of the d5 Knight and
yeah and I miss played that yeah really
yeah so around him um we have a fairly
normal position I think and you can
argue about move orders and stuff but I
rather interested in how things went
from here I'm a bit surprised that stock
fish is so skeptical about blacks
position maybe there is a way for him to
get the dreaded a 495 and under more
favorable circumstances than in the game
a form let's at least initially not like
by the engine it just wants to take a
six player form so not so easy to get
the a four-night b5 stuff and okay I'm
mostly interested in how I'm what would
I miss played how I miss played it
because I really should not lose this
game 98 yeah
hmm this was an interesting idea maybe
even going for f5 for example this is
interesting one positive point about
this f5 is that it somewhat isolates the
d5 pawned it won't then easily get some
protection by eform
the downside is of course that f5 that
weakens quite a bit light squares in
particular 96 for example would be
pretty dreadful it's not easy to get
them well an interesting alternative but
playing like this is system it was
really quite logical get rid of this and
now like an engine doesn't like that I
mean sometimes take the takes a while
for the engines to pick up the the
Bangko compensation but yeah I'm clearly
better which is not I'm not surprised I
mean Bishop h2 and I was thinking
actually that the queen is looking at
this yeah ok so this is a real issue he
doesn't have a move in this position
this is why this is so terrible I just
win 85 because he has to do something
slow is she ok okay then Queen b3 is of
course in comparison completely terrible
yeah now this said that could be the
start of things going wrong okay six
yeah I mean I was I wasn't I was simply
not sure f5 is part of this agenda you
know on my agenda anyway because my
ideas to to get this porn I was just in
thinking that this could be too slow I
was worried about this but it's um yeah
it doesn't really doesn't really work
and CM I can simply take b2 and then
okay six is definitely a problem and it
loses too much time him here this
problematic that is just not good
through the roof on 86 so here my
position was indeed excellent because of
that Bishop h2 resource which I'm mister
and I absolutely overestimated my
position here I was thinking I'm very
okay
I thought the a porn doesn't get
anywhere anytime soon and with f5 I
would basically dismantle white center
but that's not really the case
and this is a bit better but if Y does
not play a six I'm still in some in some
some trouble it's tight it's tough to
say I'm really not sure how mean I
absolutely acknowledge that I'm not
better or anything but I really wonder
if this is a justified evaluation
because I'm still very active for
example if you go on a king of seven and
six I'm not winning this pawn as I
originally thought as business just too
slow but if I can align like what the
engine gives you a king f7 he need to
and let's say just a six just go for
four being active I think the drawing
chances should still be quite reasonable
simply because like if you look at the
pieces they are really active and it's
not so clear how white is going to make
headway I came to see - yeah something
like bad rupee one is six
maybe consolidates all this and it's
just better quite like him normally such
an end games not a big issue I wonder
why it is an issue here
maybe not not certain I'm too slow I'm
just too slow with this f5 stuff
hmm yeah I mean you came the the thing
is it should never happen because you
can take on h2 but I'm a bit surprised
that this is actually pretty pretty bad
for black it seems even yeah King coming
to see to us is a huge deal for what I
mean like him maybe I have something
better than D 5 a 6
when it is active but why this why it's
better no questions okay guys thanks for
watching